[Music]
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
have a founding father of the science of
epigenetics guiding us with the best
options to obtain or maintain optimal
health. Dr. Angel
team.
>> Hello everybody. Welcome to Daily with
Doc. My name is Becca Dukes and folks,
you know what day it is? It's Friday.
It's one of our favorite days of the
week as we have pharmacist Friday with
pharmacist Ben Fuches here on Daily with
Doc. This program is being sponsored by
dailywithdoc.com,
but we are a resource for an amazing
community. So, we want to make sure that
if somebody referred you to this program
that you get back with them. They are
your person. They are the one that cared
enough about you to share this program
with you. So, make sure that you return
that favor and say thank you. They are
also going to be your first point of
contact if you have any questions about
anything that you hear about on our
programming. And if they don't know the
answer, they probably know somebody they
can connect with in order to get the
answer. Now, if you were not referred by
somebody specific and you'd like to
speak with a certified holistic health
coach, you are more than welcome to do
so. If you're not already working with
somebody, not referred to this program
by somebody specific,
and you've not tried the products that
are mentioned on this program, our
certified holistic health coach crew
here for the Daily with Doc team, it can
be reached at 855
9493377.
Now, this program is for educational
purposes only, and the man of the hour
just loves it. when I go through this,
but it is not meant to take the place of
your primary care physician, nor is it
meant to re uh treat, diagnose, or cure
any disease. But folks, there's so much
that you can do all on your own without
the need of somebody giving you a
chemical to mask the symptoms. And
that's what we're all about. So today,
our topic, it's pretty cool, actually,
because some of you may be intimidated
by this.
topic, how to speak to your doctor
sensibly about nutrition. Now, I know
that we have lots of doctors that are
joining in and and join being part of
>> wait.
Somebody take care of that, please.
Thank you so much. um being part of our
team and joining our ranks in truly
helping people not just with symptoms
but root causes.
Now the man of the hour,
pharmacist Ben Fuches is not only a
registered pharmacist but also a
brilliant formulator and nutritionist.
He is also an international speaker and
we're super excited that he has agreed
to be on with us on almost every Friday.
He has spent decades educating the
public on the powerful
intersection between pharmacy and
nutrition, helping us to understand how
our health challenges can be better
addressed through food supplementation
and lifestyle folks. And as I said, for
many of us, it can be intimidating to
bring up natural health and nutrition
with physicians.
Yet having these conversations is
essential in building a health care
partnership that works for you. Well,
pharmacist Ben will help us break down
how to approach our doctors
respectfully. We always want to do that
and how to ask the right questions
and how to confidently
advocate for your own health. So folks,
take notes, listen up as we have an
amazing program for you today as I
welcome to the screen pharmacist Ben
Fuches. Hello, pharmacist Ben. How are
you this beautiful Friday?
>> I'm great, thank you. And um I didn't
know that was going to be the topic.
That was that's an interesting surprise
for me. Uh
>> I messaged you.
>> Oh, did you today?
>> I did. like what 10 minutes ago or
something? Oh, okay. Gotcha. I didn't
>> No, about 30.
>> Okay. 30 minutes ago. Okay. Thank you.
Thank you everybody for being on the
call. Do you ever hear the phrase
begging the question?
>> I've heard the phrase.
>> It's misused often. Begging the question
is misused all the time. So, people who
have heard the phrase maybe uh are under
the impression that the misuse is the
accurate term, but it's not. So,
sometimes you hear people say begging
the question when they mean you should
be asking this question. you know, like
this is happening which begs the
question, what's going on here? That's
not what begging the question means.
That's a misuse of the term. The term
begging the question is when you the
implications of your question are wrong,
but if the person answers the question,
he's confronted with making the
implications of your question correct.
You can't answer it without making you
correct. So, the famous one without
being I don't mean to anybody, but
there's a famous one like, when did you
stop beating your wife?
That's a famous
>> Yeah, it's a famous example. I know it's
gross, but that's just a famous example
because if you answer them, it implies
that you've been beating your wife if
you answer them. I stopped yesterday.
I'd never be my wife. You know, it
forces you in a bad puts you in a bad
position. And that's exactly what you
just did with your question. You don't
talk to your doctor about nutrition.
What? What the heck? That's like talking
to your carpenter about your car. If you
have a carpenter and he's fixing your
furniture, you don't expect him to treat
your car and tell him about your engine
and ask him about what kind of oil you
should use. He's a carpenter. He doesn't
know anything about your car. He's a
great carpenter. This is the problem
we equate. Everybody on this call
probably likely or at least a lot of
people on this call and certainly the
public, the general public equate doctor
with knows everything about health.
I'm not knocking on doctors. Do we have
doctors on this call? You said we did.
We do. I love that. I love that because
as I've said many times, I hate that I
have to talk about the medical model
with the choir
and not with the physicians. So, who are
the physicians? Are there MDs on the
call?
>> Um, I did see that we have a doctor.
Where'd he go?
>> He was on the whole time before the
show. Oh, in any case, listen, I don't
like that I have to preach to the choir
because I feel like I'm talking behind
people's back and I don't like doing
that. I like being direct. That's my
style. But I'm, you know, that's just
the way it is there. It's hard to get
physicians to to cooperate, especially
physicians who disagree because if they
disagree, they're like, I don't want to
go on that call with that idiot, that
idiot Ben, that quack pharmacist Ben,
you know, which I've been called. So,
I'm going to do it any I'm I'm gonna do
what I don't want to do, which is talk
behind people's back. Doctors are not
bad people. They're not dumb people,
but we're asking them to do something
that they don't have a skill in. And why
should we expect them to other than the
fact that we equate doctors with know
know everything about health.
Doctors do not know everything about
health, nor should they have to. If you
get a broken leg
and you need it repaired, it doesn't
matter if your doctor knows about
metabolic syndrome. It doesn't matter if
your doctor knows about u leaky gut. It
doesn't matter if your doctor if your
doctor doesn't understand the link
between the digestive system and the
immune system. He doesn't have to. He's
repairing your leg. And praise God, he
can do that really well. When you have a
broken leg, you want that leg repaired.
When you have s when you have a a
trauma, god forbid something happens.
That's what doctors are for. But we've
given them this role that's not theirs
and they've taken it. You know, nature
of horse is a vacuum. And whenever you
give somebody power when you abdicate
your power, there's going to be somebody
who takes it over. It's not their job to
understand nutrition. Get it out of our
heads. That's on us.
That's on us. And that's the whole point
of this message. This is a life. The
health challenges we address here, most
of them are lifestyle,
not medical.
If you go to the doctor when you have a
lifestyle problem, you've drank the
Kool-Aid. And when he does something
incorrect or makes the problem worse or
doesn't fix you, don't blame him. That's
not his job. You're asking him to do
something that he's not skilled in. Now,
are there doctors who understand
nutrition? Yes, there are plenty. Are
there doctors who understand
biochemistry? Yes, there's plenty. But
that's gravy. That's a cherry on top.
That's not what doctoring is about. So,
we have to get this idea out of our head
that our doctors should know nutrition.
Oh, doctors only study one one semester
of nutrition. They don't need to. That's
not their job. That's our job. That's
your naturopath's job. Perhaps your
chiropractor's job. The alternative
practitioner, the doctor, the medical
model does not work with nutrition.
That's not in their skill set. Now, in
fairness, because nutrition is so
powerful, they have taken over and
they're now starting to study nutrition,
but they're still not taking a deep dive
in it. They're still not understanding
that it's about nutrition, not medicine.
And they still work with the pharmic
medical strategies of drugging you and c
and cutting you open and removing your
organs. If you go to a doctor when you
have a headache or a problem with your
skin or a problem with your menstrual
cycle and they take out your uterus and
womb, that's on you. That's not on the
doctor.
If you go uh you know, I know I told a
story before and I I'll tell it again in
case we have different people on the
call.
If the scorpion and frog are walking
down the street, there's a river.
The scorpion can the the frog can swim.
The scorpion can't. So the scorpion
says, "Hey, let me on your back and
we'll go across the river." So the frog
says, "No, I'm not going to let you on
my back. You're a scorpion. You're going
to bite me." And the frog and the
scorpion says, "I'm not going to bite
you, silly frog. If I bite you, you're
going to drown and then I'm going to
drown. That would be the stupidest thing
I could do. Why would I ever bite you?
And so the frog thinks about it for a
second. And he goes, "All right." He's,
you know, he's a he's a dumb amphibian.
He's not not a rocket scientist. He's
just a frog, brain this big. He says,
"All right, jump on my back." And and
they go in the middle of the river.
Boom. In the middle of the river, the
scorpion bites the frog. And the frog
looks up and says, "You stupid scorpion.
What did you do? You bit me. You
promised me you would. Now I'm going to
drown and you're going to drown. We're
both going to die. What were you
thinking, you stupid scorpion? The
scorpion goes, I'm a scorpion. That's
what I do,
you know, and that's how it that's how
it is. I'm a doctor. I give drugs. What
do you do? What do you come to me for?
That's what I do. I'm a doctor. I cut
out your your uterus or your thyroid or
your gallblad, whatever. That's what I
do. So, I really wanted this to hit
home. We have to start taking
responsibility for our health around
what is the most important health
challenges that human beings deal with,
which is lifestylebased
chronic degenerative disease.
Now, if it's an infection or it's a
trauma, I have a friend of mine, she's
actually a longevity person and she, you
know, she heard me and she's herself and
she's a healthcare professional, too.
She's ripped on the medical model and
she heard me ripping on it and she
perforate had a perforated colon.
Serious problem.
And she says to me, I don't want to go
to the doctor. I don't want to do that.
I don't want to, you know, I feel really
bad. I said, go have let them do what
they do. This is what they do. This is
their expertise. Nobody rips on the
medical model more than me, but if I had
a perforated colon, I'm heading to the
ER,
you know. So, we got to understand
what what we're talking about here, what
their role is and what their role isn't.
What they can do and what they can't do,
what they can do great and what they
can't do at all. We have to start taking
responsibility for our health. And the
good news is, as we talk about
everything on this program, it's simple,
not easy. Simple. Distinguish simple
from easy. There's a couple of things
you got to do. Not easy necessarily, but
it's simple. You don't need a degree.
You don't need to go to medical school.
You don't need to to study for eight
years. It's so simple because it's all
about plumbing
and the body is designed to heal.
Between the fact that it's all about
plumbing and the body is designed to
heal, all you got to do is take make a
couple of moves,
two or three moves, and pretty much
every single chronic degenerative
disease can resol can begin to resolve
itself. begin to resolve itself. Now, I
don't want anybody ever believing me.
Trust yet, verify.
Run it through your your your BS
detector or your truth detector
and see if it makes sense. And then
experiment. Scientists always
experiment. You want to be a scientist
about your health. You don't have to go
to school to be a scientist. You don't
have a degree to be a scientist. Being a
scientist is just is just a philos
science is just a philosophy, a process
where you test. Science is about testing
and then seeing the results and then
tweaking the results and and then
testing again. You make a hypothesis,
you test, you get the results, you see
how the results are, you go back to uh
fine-tune your hypothesis, you test
again and on the work for you. So when I
talk about what I'm going to talk about
here in a second, it's unfalsifiable.
Unfalsifiability means you can't find
holes in it. Can't falsify it. What I
what I've been talking about it's
unfalsifiable. So I've done the work for
you. But if you want to and which I
encourage you to do, try it yourself. So
number one, we always reduce things to
their simplest most basic components. So
you have chronic degenerative disease.
There's five thousands of them based on
diagnosis. Thousands of different ways
that your body can break down based on
diagnosis. But we reduce them all to
what they have in common. So what do
they all have in common? Well, one
thing, one way we reduce them to
commonalities is with what we used to
call the triangle of disease. And I
noticed this many years ago that
everybody who has heart problems,
cancer, uh autoimmunity, whatever a
chronic degenerative condition they
have, they all have these three points
of bodily breakdown that precede the
diagnosis.
But we simplified it even further. We
took off the top of the triangle. We
just went to the two points because the
top of the triangle really follows the
two points. And so to simplify even
further, we just work on two points.
What do these two points have in common?
These two points, by the way, are as as
AJ knows, thank you AJ for doing that
incredible website, by the way,
the digestive system and the metabolic
system or the blood sugar system.
Every single chronic degenerative
disease, everyone.
Everyone. Not 99.999%.
100% of them. There's a doctor on this
call. You you can you can affirm this or
if you disagree, get on and we'll talk
about it. D uh the digestive system, the
metabolic system. What do they have in
common though? Because we can further
reduce the digestive system and the
metabolic system. The digestive system
and the metabolic metabolic system
interact with the body through what
Becca what how do the digestive system
and the metabolic system how do they
interact with the cells? What's the
connection?
Blood,
>> blood,
blood, blood, blood. Digestive system,
metabolic system, blood.
And what is the mechanism that causes
the biochemical disruption that leads to
diabetes and thyroid problems and cancer
and heart disease? What is the actual
mechanism? There's only one.
Inflammation.
>> Inflammation.
This is a textbook. Don't you're not
going to find it on Amazon.
This is all about chronic inflammation.
All the mechanisms of chronic
inflammation. It's all inflammatory. A
all chronic degenerative disease
involves the digestive system and the
blood sugar system. B the digestive
system and blood sugar system linked to
the disease process the tissues and the
cells via the blood. C uh C the
mechanism is inflam inflammation.
If you understand what I just said, you
can understand every single chronic
degenerative disease there is and how to
reverse it.
Now when we talk about the blood sugar
system and the digestive system,
those are in the body. But how do they
get interfered with? Now we talk about
IV. You can stick things into the blood
and that's one way that the blood can
can become problematic. But how does how
do really how does the digestive system
and the metabolic system work? So
has it work in a positive sense so that
we can understand how it works in a
negative sense? Where does where does
the the digestive system the metabolic
system where does it become disturbed at
the beginning? What's the source of the
disturbance?
>> Is it the food that touches our
>> food? The mouth. The food. Listen how
simple this is. food,
digestion,
metabolic system, blood, inflammation.
Congratulations, you now have a medical
degree. That's all you need to know.
That's everything.
Food, digestion, metabolic system,
blood, inflammation.
Doctors on the call. Did I miss
anything? If there's any MDs on the
call, did I miss anything? That's it.
So, let's break this down. Inflammation.
What is inflammation?
Inflammation is a protective response.
And I hopefully everybody in this call
understands that inflammation is your
friend.
It's your best friend. Your best health
friend is inflammation. And the problem
isn't so much inflammation as it is
inflammation
and anti-inflammation.
The proportion, the balance. You're
inflaming all the time because you're
we're being attacked all the time. Even
eating lettuce creates an attack of
sorts. As soon as something gets into
the body, there's an attack. Anything,
even water, theoretically, because
there's stuff in the water. So, anything
you put in your system is going to cause
inflammation. We always have
inflammation. We live in a a world where
we're always attacked either in from the
inside through food or from the outside
through mosquitoes and bugs and trauma
and you know it's a jungle out there. So
the body has a protective system. The
inflammatory anti-inflammatory system is
our protective system. Praise God that
we have it. Inflammation under under
ordinary circumstances inflammation
initiates anti-inflammation.
Inflammation is the protective response.
Think of it like a beaver's dam
protecting something, protecting tissue.
Fibers and and uh goo. Basically, these
fibers and goose surround the bad guys.
And then that uh inflammatory
the inflammatory biochemistry they call
the inflammatory cascade initiates
anti-inflammation and you heal. And
that's the that's what's supposed to
happen. But because of chronic attack,
we ne we don't give the body a chance to
get into the anti-inflammatory phase. We
are chronically attacking the body
through food.
Well, how are we chronically attacking
the body through food? Because we're not
eating from our stomachs. We're eating
from our brain. We're not eating from
our digestive system. We're eating from
our head.
And we have created a corporate culture,
a uh
a a f economic system that depends on us
eating from our head
and
encourages us to eat from our head so
that it will become more economically
viable, make more money. So there's all
of this incentive to eat from our head
and not from our belly. And you can test
this out. Again, everything should be
tested. First of all, if you want to
test out this relationship between the
digestive system and the blood sugar
system and food and inflammation and and
blood and disease, fast for two days and
watch what happens to your symptoms.
If you want to test out the hypothesis
that the theory that I just gave you
that says that um that we're eating from
our brain, not from our our stomach,
don't eat today or don't eat for the
rest of the day. And then when it comes
time to eat at dinner, put a big plate
of food on the table and then eat the
food really slowly and watch how long it
takes for you to be full.
You'll be full in two bites or three
bites. You want, if you watch, pay close
attention, you will notice that you're
full way before you stop eating.
Way before. Usually in a few bites. Your
stomach is this big. Size your fist. So
number one, f just fast. Test it fast.
If you have chronic pain, fast. You'll
notice your pain's resolved resolved. If
you have rashes, if you have movement
disorders, Parkinson's disease, notice
what happens when you fast. And notice
how quickly it take how qu how uh little
it takes to be satisfied to be to and
then you'll see how much you're eating
from your brain because your brain will
say, "Let's keep eating." Or you'll be
bored or you say, "That tastes del
that's delicious. I got to eat that." Or
you'll say, "I don't want to waste the
food." There's all these little conco
little little um kind of strategies that
we have to keep eating and we do and all
of this costs us and I'm not Mr. Food
guy. I told you a million times I'm not
Mr. Food guy. I'm just saying this is a
point of power that we have. So all
disease is inflammatory. Inflammation is
an attack. The attack comes in for the
vast majority of us through uh through
the intestine into the blood.
How does it start off in the intestine
to get into the blood? Through the
mouth. Everything. Everything. There.
Uh, cancer. Obviously, the most horrible
diagnosis a person can have. And if you
go to the hospital, they'll tell you,
"Make sure you eat. You don't want to
waste away. You don't want to get your
count." Wrong. Go get a book called
Fasting Cancer. Literally fasting.
That's the name of the book. It talks
all about the benefits of fasting for
cancer. Ketogenic diet, low calorie, by
the way. Ketogen diet is a lowc calorie
diet. This is such a powerful technique
for all of us. Now once the intestine
becomes damaged which is occurs for most
of us at a very young age. For many of
us the intestine becomes damaged by the
first year of life particularly if
you're not um if you're not uh being
breastfed the baby's not being breastfed
but even with breast milk it can happen.
You had this one two punch of disease.
The one two the first punch is leaky gut
where literally I don't want to get into
leaky gut. We talked about it a million
times but basically the gut becomes
permeable and stuff gets into the blood.
And by the way when I say stuff gets
into the blood
I'm talking about yucky stuff that you
usually see in the toilet. That's what's
getting into the blood.
If you've ever
thrown up
that stuff that you see that's coming
from your intestine.
That's what it looks like. And that's
the stuff that gets into the blood. You
think that's a problem? You think that
can be a problem? You think the stuff
that's in your stool gets into your
bloodstream? You think that's a problem?
And this happens chronically for some
people.
And keep in mind, the blood is not just
some fluid, some red stuff. The blood is
a very complex
organ tissue structure that has to be
kept just perfectly so that with
temperature and pH and fluidity and
oxygen levels and particulate levels and
and temperature and and uh viscosity and
coagulation. Everything is just
balanced. Now you put vomit in there and
and and fecal material in there. What do
you think's going to happen? Of course
you're going to get sick. Oh, I'm gonna
go to the doctor for that and he's going
to fix me. Really? What's he gonna do?
Oh, he's gonna give me a pill. Oh my
god, I can't believe he gave me that.
Oh, he's going to he's going to take
care of it. Oh, I can't believe he took
my organ out. What do you expect?
So, we got to stop blaming the doctor.
We got to return back to our own become
our own health authorities. And it's
simple to do, if not easy. That's why we
talk about food so much. That's why we
talk about nutritional supplementation.
I tell you the second punch on the the
one two punches. Now you don't absorb
your vitamins. Once you have intestinal
inflammation, now you don't absorb your
minerals. Now you don't absorb your
electrolytes.
Likely you're not going to absorb your
fats and your fatty vitamins.
So can you see you got this? You got all
that literal crap getting into your
blood and you're starving.
What do you think's going to happen? Oh,
but I'm going to go to the doctor. He's
going to take care of it. He'll say,
"Oh, sure. Come on in. I'll take care of
it. You know, no problem. I got I got my
co I got a Mercedes and I got a college
my kids in college and I got af.
So, what do you do? A food diary. First
thing anybody with a chronic
degenerative disease does, you need
data. Any, this is a scientific process.
Any scientific process, you need data.
So, you get data. You collect the data.
that is you do if you're a doctor or
nurse and you're in the hospital, you're
charting. If you're a police, if you're
a detective and there's a crime, you
take notes.
This is a crime. We're doing forensics
here.
It's all forensics. I talked to a a
pharmacist actually uh traditional
pharmacist and and her husband and the
baby had this deep rash on his butt.
Deep rash, not surface, but deep.
I had to tell him the lymph is low.
There's major lymph glands underneath
there. Once the lymph becomes clogged,
all kinds of stuff gets put into the
skin. She's been going to a
dermatologist. This is not a dermatology
problem. She can't believe the
dermatologist gave antibiotics. It
didn't help. Really? No kidding.
Even health care professionals don't
understand what I'm saying. If you
understand what I'm saying here, you're
smarter than many health care
professionals. So, first things first,
always a food diary. Always. And it
helps if you fast before you do your
food diary because if you fast then you
notice things more clearly and then you
start eliminating foods. And don't go by
lists.
Don't go by diets. Don't go by what you
think is good. Oh, but I'm gluten-free.
It doesn't matter if you're symptomatic.
It doesn't matter.
If you're symptomatic, assume
something's getting into the blood and
work from that point. That's your
hypothesis. You work from that point.
Doesn't matter if you're vegetarian. It
doesn't matter if you're organic. It
doesn't matter if you're just eating the
Mediterranean diet or the ketogenic
diet, whatever you are. If you're
symptomatic, you can assume something's
getting into the blood. And unless it's
coming in through the skin, it's coming
in through the intestine. So, you do
food diary, start eliminating the the
eliminating the problem foods. Then you
start building the lining of the
intestine. And simultaneous with
building the lining of the intestine,
you uh correct the environment of the
intestine. The lumen, they call it the
lumen. It's the inside of the intestine.
You correct the intestinal lumen and
that involves bacteria
largely. Now, we have a great product,
one of my one of my favorite longevity
products. I have a few called I26.
Oops. I don't know if you can see it,
but it's called I26. There's different
versions of it. This is the version I
like. It's a powder. Anybody who has a
chronic degenerative disease will
benefit from this because if you
understand the mechanism, you understand
that there's bacteria that are involved.
They call that disbiosis, by the way.
And the I26 will correct dispiosis.
Once you correct the disbiosis a little
bit, then you can start using
probiotics. You can probably use
probiotics ahead of time, but if you
have SIBO, small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth, and you put bacteria in
there, sometimes people have problems.
If you can, if you don't have problems,
then you're okay. Okay. But I recommend
people do the I26 first and then get on
the nightly essence. One of the great
things about Youngevity is the wonderful
digestive support supplements and they
keep adding more. I don't even know all
of them at this point because they keep
adding more. Uh ultimate microbiome
which is fiber. Dr. Ariz's liver cleanse
which is kind of the liver and the
gallbladder are not exactly the
intestine but there's related to the
intestine. There's communication there.
So Dr. as far as liver cleanse, the
ultimate enzymes, which is not going to
work directly on the intestine, but work
higher up. Uh, and by the way, the
ultimate enzymes are great blood
cleanser, too, and that's a whole
another story. Um, and then, uh, there's
also the daily digest capsules
that come in or or not, packets, which
come in 30 packets. And there you go.
Thank you, AJ. So, got great digestive
supplements. Then you do liquid
nutrition. Why liquid nutrition? Because
liquid nutrition will bypass, at least
partially bypass
intestinal inflammation. Remember, if
the intestine is inflamed, it can't
absorb its nutrients. It's much harder
for it to absorb its nutrients. If you
can liquefy those nutrients, they're
easier to process. Not completely. You
still got to get rid of the
inflammation, but it's easier. So,
Rockstar right here. I know there's
different versions. I know there's the
rise and restore and I'm supposed to
promote the rise and restore and I know
they got the tablets and I'm supposed to
stop at the table. This is the best
right here. Put it in water, drink it
all day long.
Then you start uh that's your liquid
nutrition. Bone broth also bone broth
does double duty. Bone broth also in
addition to being protein, liquid
protein and liquid connective tissue, it
also is very soothing for the intestine
and it also calms down inflammation. So
bone broth is got multi is
multifunctional and vegetable juices.
You got to be a little careful with
vegetables because some people react to
certain vegetables. But vegetables are
mucilaginous
slimy. Slimy stuff is great for the
intestine. Slimy stuff coats the
intestine and supports immunity. So
anything slimy, a bone broth is somewhat
slimy. Uh vegetable juices, if you do
them right, can be slimy. uh and also um
one of the best slimy substances for the
intestine and for the blood for that
matter is fucoidin fucoid z so fucoidin
and also collagen peptides and collagen
and also tmr shake these are all in the
interest of strengthening the lining
anything with vitamin A in it is also
beneficial one of the most egregious uh
attack uh enemies of the intestine by
the way
is
the famous
processed fats
which are inflammatory for everything
but especially inflammatory for the
body. By the way, quick digression. The
inflammatory system
which which is inflammation and
anti-inflammation. I'm calling it the
inflammatory system but it's two phases
runs on fat.
Fats are the major players in the
inflammatory system.
Which means you have to be very careful
with the kind of fats you put into your
body. One of the things we've done over
the last 120 or 130 years in this
country is we've destroyed our fats
through processing and heating. So many
of us are subsisting on fried and
processed fats and if not subsisting at
least indulging and these are very
inflammatory for the intestine as well
as for the entire system.
So making sure that not only you're
watching what you're putting into the
body, but also what you're
say putting the good stuff in. You also
got to make sure you're keeping the bad
stuff out. In addition to the things
you're going to find on your food diary,
you got to stay away from the processed
fats and the heated fats. And that's why
I say simple but not easy because it's
very difficult to wean yourself off of
French fries and pizza and fried okra
and hush puppies and you know all the
things we like to eat that are fried
fats. Not to mention, you know, there's
fried fats and baked goods or not fried
fats, but processed fats and baked
goods. So, when you're eating baked
goods, even from whole foods, even from
a health food store, you're eating baked
goods, you're going to have processed
fats in there. One of the most evil
sources of processed fats is in formula
for babies.
And I know there's some kids who can't
breastfeed. I understand. Or some moms
who can't breastfeed. I understand that.
But that's a problem because the
replacements
are loaded with these inflammatory fats
and because nobody talks about them,
nobody knows about them, nobody cares
about them, the companies have no
incentive to not do it.
By the way, many things that we inject
through our skin that our doctors tell
us to, if you know what I'm talking
about, contain inflammatory fats. In
fact, that recent injection that all our
brilliant medical people and government
people said that we should all be
injecting or else we can't go to work or
we can't fly on a plane. You know what
I'm talking about? Those contained
inflammatory fats and nobody even
thought about that. Everybody's all
focused on, you know, the other stuff
which is not great either.
So, you work on the digestive system.
Then the second phase is the metabolic
system because in addition to toxicity
that gets into the blood,
we're also driving energy into cells.
Now, first of all, and this is sugar,
and by the way, fructose counts. Fruit
sugar counts, although in fruits at
least it's a little better, but fruit
juice is a problem. And high fructose
corn syrup, which is a replacement for
sugar, is also a problem, particularly
for the liver.
So these sugars do these these uh uh
high concentrations of sugars do a
couple things. First of all, sugar is
costic. It burns burns hot. And in the
blood when the hot when the levels are
high,
you can burn your blood vessels.
If you're burning your blood vessels,
glycation they call it, by the way. They
don't call it burning, they call it
glycation. If you're burning your blood
vessels, glycating your blood vessels,
the inside lining of the blood vessels
will start to get destroyed. They'll
start to burn. They'll start to the
cells will break down and then they will
become
inflamed.
Remember inflammation anytime where you
have damage you have inflammation
because inflammation is protective. The
inflammatory response
in the blood vessels will disturb blood
flow.
Now, under these these conditions of
disturbed blood flow,
the blood isn't going to make it to the
tissues and the organs and the cells and
the brain will see, "Oh my gosh, the
spleen is not getting enough oxygen. The
intestine is not getting enough oxygen,
the heart's not getting enough oxygen.
We got to turn up the pressure." and the
brain will turn up the pressure in order
to get more blood which is not moving
because for a lot of reasons but for one
reason because the sugar is inflaming
the the lining. So of course your doctor
will say oh you have essential
hypertension we got to put you on a beta
blocker completely oblivious to the fact
that the body is turning up the pressure
so it doesn't so the tissues don't die
so they don't suffocate.
Sugar itself will thicken the blood.
So now the blood becomes thick from the
blood vessels and it becomes thick from
the from the from the inflammatory
factors that are coming in from the
digestive system and it becomes thick
from the sugar.
When the blood gets filtered through the
kidneys, the kidney blood vessels are
really tiny and everything that I just
talked about in the regular blood
vessels becomes even more problematic in
the tiny blood vessels in the kidney and
now you got kidney problems which are
epidemic by the way and they're always
related to thick sludgy sticky blood. So
you work in the blood sugar system.
What's worse is the little structures
inside of cells. the little structures
inside of cells that convert energy that
convert food energy into chemical energy
or food molecules into chemical energy
because they have so much energy coming
in they're burning out.
Those are called those little structures
are called what? Mitochondria.
And today
mitochondrial medicine and mitochondrial
burnout is recognized as an important
part of chronic disease. and of healing,
which is another reason why you fast and
why you reduce your sugar and why you
lower your calories. And by the way, one
of the things diabetics notice all the
time is they're really thirsty.
Why do you think diabetics are really
thirsty all the time? Because their
blood is so thick and sludgy that their
body is saying, "Dilute the blood
quickly." You can you can mitigate a lot
of the problems just by diluting your
blood prophylactically or preventatively
first thing in the morning and
throughout the day. So what are we
saying here? We're saying here, this is
not difficult. It's not medical. It's
not doctor. We can be our own health
authority. We can do it ourselves.
Reduce your calories. Get on the
ketogenic diet. Give McDonald's the
finger as you're passing by. Don't drive
through. Drive by. They're not your
friends. And if you unwrap a Snickers
bar and and indulge in it, that's on
you. There's no ever any need for a
Snickers bar. And I'm just picking on
Snickers bar because you can say M&M's
and you can say anything. They're not.
There's no need for that stuff. And I'm
not beating anybody up for their food.
I'm just saying this is a point of
leverage for us. And get on a
nutritional supplement program,
everybody. It is so important. And as
you know, obviously, we're all here
because of longevity, but if you
complaining about this or that, get on
something. I don't you're not going to
find any better than Beyond Tang
Tangerine. for people who can't afford a
lot of a lot of uh nutritional
supplementation or I don't know how you
to me this is an important something you
have to afford cut lose the cable TV and
get on a nutritional supplement program
at the very least get on the BTT and
don't blame the doctors because you know
what I've worked in hospitals and I've
been in hospitals as a patient I've been
in ER and I've been in the operating
room the people that work in hospitals
are saints they're angels from God are
there bad apples yes there's some bad
apples for sure. But the vast majority
of them are beautiful, beautiful people.
And when I worked in hospitals, I
noticed that people were coming, the
same people would go back all the time.
And you know why they went back all the
time? Because of the love, the amount of
love and compassion and empathy that you
get when you're in the hospital or in
the emergency room or when you're
suffering is over the top. So I don't I
don't you'll never hear me beating up on
doctors and nobody should beat up on
doctors. It's the model, the paradigm,
and it's on us. And that's I know
everybody's I'm getting the he I'm
getting some You guys want to say
something or kick me off or something? I
didn't see you, AJ. I'm just ignoring
you.
>> So,
I knew that that title would fire you
up.
>> Oh, you did that on purpose. You did
that.
>> Well, no. AJ did it. And I'm thinking in
my mind, oh, this is gonna get him
fired.
>> Oh, yeah. It does. It does.
>> I love my doctor friends. They're
beautiful people. I don't want to How do
you talk to your doctor about nutrition?
It's not on them. They're beautiful
people. Go ahead. I'm sorry. Do we want
to take some questions?
>> Well, pharmacist Ben, we have lots of
questions. Okay.
>> So, AJ's first. He's been like going
crazy. I know.
>> Let's get to questions. Let's get to
questions. Go ahead.
>> Okay. Yes. But my question is not that
important at this point because, you
know, I'll see you on Monday at 10 PM.
>> Yes. Um, but uh the the reason that the
title is the title is because we really
wanted to say how do we talk to our
doctor about getting off our medication.
>> Okay. So that's good. That's different.
>> But but as opposed but we didn't want to
get banned. So
>> Okay. So I got you. This is how you talk
to your doctor about getting off your
medication. First of all, people often
I'll hear this all the time and this
kind of bugs me. My doctor said I have
to be on this. My doctor ordered this.
My doctor made me take that. No, you
decide, not him. Okay? You decide, not
him. That's first of all. Second of all,
if you're working with a doctor, you
have a de facto contract. You haven't
signed a contract. Literally, I know
that, but you have an implied contract
with him. You're going to listen to him.
And when I'm counseling somebody, AJ,
and Becca, you can I'm sure you can
relate to this. You don't want somebody
else coming in and say, "No, do this. Do
that." aside from just making the
patient go crazy and being confused,
it's not fair to the person who's trying
to heal them. So, you never do
something, you never do something behind
your doctor's back or um ask other
people to to recommend other things when
you're going to a doctor. You're going
to a doctor, you got a relationship with
him, you have to do you you have to
cooperate with him. That doesn't mean
you do everything he says, though. That
doesn't mean you do everything he says.
You ask questions. You should be asking,
"What does this medication do? uh what
are the side effect and you can do your
own re these days you don't have to ask
you do your own research
it's your right to wean yourself off of
any med and it should be your number one
health goal if you're on a med one of
the by med I mean a chronic long-term
med your number one health goal should
be to figure out how to wean wean
yourself off and you do it with your
doctor and if he says no no no I want
you on this you find another doctor
there's no legal obligation that you
have to do what he tells tells you to do
if you feel strongly about it. So, you
say, "No, doc. I want to I don't want
the med. I understand I'll be on it
temporarily, but I want to wean myself
off of it." But you can't just say, "I'm
not taking the med." If you have been
mucking up your biochemistry through
lifestyle choices for 30 or 40 or 50
years, you can't just say, "I'm not
going to take the med." Because the med
may be keeping you in the game. And yes,
there's a toxic side effect. And yes,
you're going to deplete your body of
precious nutrients. And yes, there's
when the body when you put a drug in the
body, the body does everything it do to
get rid of it because it recognizes it
as a poison and a toxin, but it may be
keeping you in the game. It may be
keeping you from getting a stroke. You
know, if you have had if you have blood
clots, for example, blood thinners are a
nasty, nasty drug, but if you have blood
clots, you can't just say, "I'm going to
just not take the drug." Because the
blood thinner may be keeping you from
having a a heart attack or a stroke and
maybe saving your life. But you want to
start to do the lifestyle choices, make
the lifestyle choices that will allow
you to wean yourself off the med. And
that's the goal. If you're on a
prescription drug, a chronic drug for
the rest of your life, you your goal
should be get off of that. But you don't
just stop taking it if you haven't
corrected all of the causes that led you
to have to take it in the first place.
So you talk to your doctor and most
doctors these days are understanding.
They understand if you find a doctor
who's not. No, no, that's crazy. Who'd
you hear that from? Dr. Google? from
pharmacist Ben from those quacks, you
know, find another doctor. It's your
right to find another doctor. Find one
who will work with you and who
understands that you don't want to get
better by taking poison even though you
may know that you have to in the short
term.
>> Does that answer?
>> Thank you.
>> I think that answers the question
>> perfectly. So, let's go over to the next
question. And Phyllis is bringing in a
question from somebody here that is live
with us. So, I'm gonna ask her.
>> Find the MDs while we're while we're on
the call here. Find the MDs if they are
on the call. I would love to have one
pop up.
>> Ben, we've got we've got a question from
Tracy. She is here. I've asked her if
she wants to come on.
>> Tracy from Australia.
>> Um Oh, yes.
>> Oh, yeah. Come on, Tracy. Let's see your
pretty face.
>> Um I'm actually currently in Canada
right now and I'm actually with my dad.
uh my dad. So, I figured he's having
some issues and there wasn't anybody I
couldn't think that could really help us
go through this. Um we've discovered
he's had some mobility issues and I
noticed some tremors happening and I
knew intuitively something was not
right. Uh he had a heart attack in 2016
and since then they have him on a
aspirin, a heart pill, a uh what do you
call it?
>> What's a heart pill? Do you know
>> the heart pill? I can tell you exactly.
And then they have them on blood
pressure tablets and they have them on
two cholesterol loing tablets, a
sleeping pill. And then I discovered
that they got him on this pill called
olampine which is like an
anti-depressant
depression one which the side effect is
exactly all these sort of things. Um so
you can imagine
>> you now you see Tracy this is the the
craziness of it. So in Canada
>> my dad is very open. He's actually
sitting here with me right now. So
>> okay good. All right. So, let let me
just say a couple things. First of all,
I love my friends in Canada. I I when I
was a kid, I wanted to move to Canada. I
went and visited Australia and New
Zealand about 10 years ago. I wanted to
move there. There's so beautiful,
beautiful people, beautiful country.
What's happening with your medical and
health system is so twisted and so evil
because it's free. And so anybody who
thinks free medicine is somehow going to
be our savior for healthare uh just look
at New Zealand and Canada and and
Australia once you give the medical
model medical paradigm the pharmicomemed
paradigm the imprintor the authority of
the government you're off to the races
the disease races and it's horrible it's
bad here in this country but it's
terrible in Canada you're on no human
being should ever be on multiple drugs
if you have to take one maybe two,
that's one thing. But to have somebody
who's on five different drugs or six
different drugs, especially an elderly
person, and by the way, 60% of Americans
over the age of 65 are on five or more
prescription drugs, that's called
polyfarm pharmacy. It's idiotic. Okay?
Now, I'm not blaming the doctor here.
I'm not blaming the doctor. This is the
model. So, who the heck knows what's
going on in terms of the this hydracy?
Who who the heck knows what's going on
in terms of this guy's b your dad's
biochemistry once you're on all these
multiple drugs it's a cocktail nobody
knows in pharmacy school when something
happened like that we didn't understand
we go to the blackboard the professor go
to the blackboard he write o gk only god
knows and that's the only person that's
the only entity being that will know
what that cocktail is doing in your poor
dad's body now
>> I'm guessing I'm seeing your dad over
here so I'm guessing
>> that's correct that's correct
What's his name? What's your dad's name?
>> His name is Wayne.
>> Hi, Wayne. So, I'm guessing you're in
your 70s,
>> Wayne. Correct.
>> Yeah. 71.
>> Okay. You had your heart attack when you
were 61. 10 years ago, you said.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah.
>> So, something had been going on for a
very long. 61, believe it or not, is
young. So, we have a heart attack at 61.
That tells me something's been going on
for a long time that's not been
corrected. And because you don't know
what that is, likely it's still
happening. Well, the good news I can
tell you, the good news I can share is
he was smoking and he was taking patches
and a lot of things accumulate. He's
since quit smoking. He's quit drinking.
He's
>> all good. All good.
>> He's all done, but they still have him
on all these meds. And that's why,
>> well, like I was just saying,
>> I said two things. First of all, your
number one goal is to get off the meds,
but I don't know what your situation is
that the meds are keeping you in the
game. There are some meds in there that
are not keeping you in the game. They
are gratuitous,
egregious. They're not. They're just
throwing them in now. The
anti-depressant,
you don't look you don't look thrilled
to be around here. The anti-depressant
doesn't seem like it's working that
great, Wayne. So, what's the point of
that right away? You you have to
understand the costbenefit ratio,
costbenefit relationship. So, if it's
not helping you, but it has a cost,
what's the point right now? The really
probably Tracy and and Wayne, you could
verify this. you're probably taking
because the doctor said to take it and
you're not, you know, who am I to
question the doctor? The doctor said,
"Take it. I take it." Right? And that's
how most people do it. No knock on
anybody. That's just what we do. So,
right away, you can probably reduce some
big load on the body by getting off that
anti-depressant. Now, I'm not telling
you to do that. Like I said earlier, you
have a relationship with the doctor and
it's none. I can't stick my nose in that
relationship. You have to do that. But
that's what I would do. I'd say, "Doc, I
don't really need this antipress. Not
help me anyway. And now I just got more
work for my liver to do and I'm already
my liver is already overloaded. So
that's one thing. Cholesterol drugs,
what's the point of that? You're on two
different cholesterol drugs. So now I I
got more stuff for my liver. What's the
cholesterol drug going to do? So your
body produces cholesterol
in high concentrations
largely
because of sugar. There's other reasons
too, but mostly because of sugar. So,
the best way to lower your cholesterol
is to lower your blood sugar and
insulin. And that's all diet. That's the
best. We'll do it maybe next week. We
can talk about cholesterol. I know we've
done it before, but but that's very
important.
>> Got him to watch.
>> The most important Tracy, take this back
to Australia, New Zealand. The most
important reason why cholesterol goes up
is because blood sugar goes up. Elevated
insulin and elevated blood sugar are the
most important cause of elevated
cholesterol. There's some other reasons,
too. And that involves steroid hormones
and stress and repair. But cholesterol
is not the enemy.
It's a meme. It's a a a
mental shortcut. Oh, the cholesterol is
high, so it's blocking the vessels and
your heart's working harder. Nonsense.
Cholesterol is a vital molecule. Vital.
Vital. vital. And by the way,
cholesterol suppression can lead to
brain problems like depression. So
that's a second thing I would be asking
the doctor why he absolutely needs to be
on that as well. And then what were the
other ones? You said a beta blood two
blood pressure medicines.
>> Yeah. So well no a blood pressure
medicine for kidney function.
>> Okay. Um
>> and then the heart medicine.
>> And then the heart one. And the heart
one you asked what it was called. It's
called isoprool
fumate.
>> Fumart. Spell it. Spell it. spell
instead of trying to say it.
>> Okay. B I S.
>> Yeah.
>> O P R O L O L.
>> Okay. Got you. That's a bit That's
That's O L O. Whenever you hear a drug
that ends O L O.
>> Yeah.
>> That's called a beta blocker.
>> That's what I thought.
>> All OOL's are beta blockers.
>> Mtopol, propranol, such as that.
Whenever you hear Ool, you're talking
about a beta blocker. Beta blockers,
like the name implies, block
the nervous system. The beta nervous
system.
Who in their right mind would think
blocking your nervous system is a good
idea?
>> It's the silliest thing.
Your heart is obviously in a position
where it's really working hard and
they're trying to calm it down, but
they're calming it down by poisoning it.
So what you're I your dad's life can
change today if he does just a few
things. Now I'm not telling you to get
off the drugs because you got to get off
you're going to have to do gradually and
you want to work with your doctor.
Number one, the most important thing he
can do at this point is he's starving
and malnourished.
And on top of being starving and
malnourished, he's piling on work for
his body to do.
So not only he's putting more burdens on
his body as he's starving.
You see, you see a problem here. Get him
on the BTT today. Right now, while I'm
on the cause, you can't do it soon
enough. The BTT has it's not doesn't
have enough of everything. It has pretty
much as broad spectrum as you're going
to find in a supplement. You still need
more, but this is a start. And because
it's liquid, it'll go right to work.
Small doses and build up on the doses. I
don't know who put the two scoops in the
glass of water thing here. That's crazy
to me. small doses build up. And for
everybody out there who's starting a BTT
program or starting a client on BTT, if
the digestive system is not prepared,
you're you're going to have a and you do
uh the dose that says on the label,
you're going to have a very unhappy
customer,
okay? And I'm sure you guys know what
I'm talking about.
Explosive diarrhea and cramping and
bloating and discomfort. Because if your
digestive system is not prepared and you
try to pound the nutrients in here,
you're going to overload the system. So,
you want to do small doses and build up
to them and find a place where he likes
the taste. Soon as you get off the call,
Tracy, put a teaspoon of water, drink
it. You and watch your dad while he's
drinking it. I'm telling you, it'll be
like a plant that hasn't been watered.
You ever see a plant hasn't been
watered, you go on vacation, forget to
water it, and then you water it and you
can like see it all of a sudden within
like a minute or two it's like starting.
That's going to be your dad. Mhm.
>> And by the way, everybody out there for
Christmas, if you know anybody who's ill
or elderly or in a nursing home
recovering from surgery, best Christmas
gift ever.
>> So get them on the BTT. That's first of
all, you need much more than that. I
suspect that this whole thing was
initiated by digestive issues, which it
usually is. So, you haven't mentioned
anything about digestive issues, but
when I hear that somebody has this kind
of breakdown at this young age, there's
probably some been some long-standing
digestive issues and he probably hasn't
corrected them because he doesn't know.
So, God bless you for being there
because you can do it. Just work with
him with specific foods and the
connection between the foods and the
intestine because that's where it all
begins. if he's a sugar eater, if he
likes the bread and the pasta and the
potatoes and the sweets and the fruit
juice and all those kinds of things as
best as you can wean him off and lots of
BTT after or with those kinds of foods.
And I would get him on the whole healthy
brain heart pack. Of course, if you can
do that, that would be awesome if you
can do that. Um, and then low calorie.
The less food he eats, the better off
he's going to be because that means less
work for his body to do. The more work
your body does digesting food, the less
energy it has for healing.
>> So it's basically, do I want to digest
my food or do I want to heal and grow
and repair? Obviously, you we know the
answer. So, so we wean him off the
calories and the more nutrients he does,
the less hungry he'll be. So that'll be
easier. You can do all of this today or
tomorrow in the very near future and you
can change his life so quickly it's
going to blow you away. Now there's way
more way more and you're and and Wayne
Tracy is you're well equipped. You got a
awesome daughter who understands the
business and understands nutrition.
You're in good hands and I'm happy to
help. But just do that what I just said
right there. Also soups and juices.
Remember the intestines inflamed. You
got to assume his intestines inflamed at
this point. So, liquid nutrition in
addition to the BTT, fruits and juice,
uh fruits, but uh vegetable juices and
soups, especially bone soup. TMR shake
wouldn't hurt either. Smoothie, TMR
shake with smooth a smoothie with TMR
shake. Crack an egg in there if you can
do eggs.
>> Okay,
>> we've been doing it. We've been working
on it. So, this
>> Wayne, we can change you can change life
today. Send me a note. Send me a note.
Tell me what happened.
>> I'll keep you posted, Ben. Thank you so
much. And thank you. You don't have an
Australian accent, Tracy.
>> I'm Canadian. I'm Canadian. I've been in
Australia 25 years. My dad visits as
often as he can. This is my visit. I
kind of made him more of a quick trip
just to kind of assess what's going on
because he has cleaned up his diet. We
do have him on the products, but
something was holding him back,
>> which is all his meds.
>> All his meds. Exactly. There. That's not
only is it a burden on the body, all
those meds, but now he's nutritionally
deficient because the body's using the
nutrients to detoxify.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Thank you, Tracy. I hope I helped and
I'd love to hear back from you.
>> Thank you. I will.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you, Wayne. God bless you, my
friend. God bless you.
>> Thank you.
>> Let's take one more call here.
>> Pharmacist Ben, we have one from Vlad on
YouTube. He has a family member, a woman
79 years old, stage five liver problems.
Can she come out of this? We don't know
about other health issues.
>> You know, st obviously she's pretty
progressed. Uh she's probably on a lot
of meds. it. You know,
I don't want to say never for anybody.
There's always hope. Immediately, you
got to reduce the load on the liver. The
major loads on the liver are food,
sugar, and drugs.
So, less calories, low calories,
ketogenic diet. Um, actually, you got to
be a little careful with the ketogenic
diet because of the fats, but she
probably has she probably have a problem
processing fats. I don't know if she's
had all I don't know if she has all her
organs. There's a lot of things I need
to know in order to really give you an
accurate to give you accurate advice,
but the main principle is to reduce the
load on the liver from food, from sugar,
and from drugs and immediately put
nutrients into the system beyond tank
tangerine for sure. But if you can get
on the healthy star pack, that would be
great. There's way too many things I'd
have to ask this person to be able to
give him accurate advice, but basically
you want to reduce the load on the
liver. That's the strategy for all liver
issues and the major loads are going to
be calories, sugar, and um toxins in
general, drugs being the most important
toxins. Hi Mary.
>> Mary gonna ask a question.
>> Hi.
>> Hi. Have I met you before? CWC,
certified wellness health coach.
>> Yes. Can you hear me?
>> Yes. And I love your place on the beach.
It's gorgeous.
>> This is where I want to be for sure.
>> I love it. That's beautiful. Yes. I want
to be there, too. What's going on, Mary?
Yes. Yes. I actually um I'm kind of
subbing in and I do have a question from
YouTube.
>> You're subbing for who? For Ruth Allen.
>> I'm subbing for anyone that uh is not
here.
>> Okay, fair enough. Nice to see you.
>> Yes, good to see you as well. Uh my
question is from Hunter uh 2847.
He says he I believe says uh does inter
interception
require
>> interosception.
>> That could be he he's he spells it I n
tu
s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s
ss u s c e p p p p p p p p p p p p p p p
p p p p p t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t
t t t t t i o n that inception. I don't
know.
>> Yeah, require surgery or not.
>> I don't know what that is. Like
>> define it, Mary.
>> Yes. Hold on. My def the definition here
is uh it's a medical condition where
part of the intestine slides into an
adjacent part of the intestine.
>> Yeah.
>> Similar to how sections of a telescope
slide into each other and
>> this is a rule of thumb here. Okay, I
got you. Interception. Yeah. Intest.
Intestception. Yes. Rule of thumb. Don't
mess with your intestine
>> ever. If it's a mechanical issue like
that, have it fixed. There's no
nutritional strategy for that. Do not
mess with your digestive system. Like I
said earlier, and I don't mean to be
graphic, but I want everybody to really
feel this and hear this and understand
this. That's where your crap is.
You guys get that? You don't you want
that in out the body. Anything that's
messing around there, you don't want
that anywhere near your body. If the
intestine, if anything happens to the
intestine, a a perforation or a growth
or a polip or anything, that's could be
serious serious danger. So, no, I would
not I'd have that. I would have that
mechanically or whatever they need to do
to get that taken care of. And
strangulations and all kinds of weird
intestinal things can happen and they
can be fatal and I wouldn't mess around
with that.
>> Okay. Thank you very much.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Pharmacist Ben, do you have
time for one more?
>> One more quickie.
Okay, so Denise wants to know what's the
best way to get rid of heavy metal
metals and aluminum in the body.
>> Okay, I want to talk about heavy metals
next time, too. By the way, that's a
good topic. Um, and then is this Denise
Lantly Lander, I think.
>> Yes.
>> Hi, Denise. Can you come on? I want to
see Denise. I I invited her on.
>> Um, let me go ahead and get her
>> Denise has been great. She actually she
actually jumped through a lot of hoops
to get here. So, let's give her let's
give her a hand.
You there, Denise?
>> Hi.
>> Hi, Denise.
>> Yeah, I'm here. I I don't see my
picture. Hi, Ben.
>> Oh, I wanted to see you. I want to see.
Come on. We're all
>> Go ahead and turn your camera on,
Denise.
>> Come on, Denise. Let's see what you look
like.
I want to see who I'm talking to.
>> I don't know how.
>> Okay, don't worry about that. Don't
worry about for now. I'm sorry.
>> I don't know where it is. I tried
clicking on that one.
>> One of the best detoxifying supplements
for heavy metals is right here, Beyond
Tangy Tangerine. And I forgot to mention
this is also great for the blood too for
as a blood cleanser. Um beyond tangy
tangerine the me the minerals the
colloidal minerals and the ionic
minerals in BTT are one of the best ways
to detoxify heavy metals to purify heavy
metals. You can also use the fucoid.
>> You can also use the fucoid Z. You can
also use the CFX and the ultimate
selenium and the MSM. Those are all
keelating agents uh that will keelate
heavy metals. But please recognize and
all the young distributors should know
that beyond tangy tangerine and planter
minerals in general are wonderful heavy
metal detoxifiers.
So let's talk
>> you can take it throughout throughout
the day right
>> way you do it
you know scratch the surface of the
benefits of beyond tangerine and the
minerals. Go ahead. I'm sorry, Denise.
>> Yeah. Uh, the water that you mix it
with, a lot of the municipal systems
don't take out all the heavy metals, do
they? Water.
>> You don't ever want You don't ever want
to drink municipal water. You don't even
want to give your dog municipal water.
You don't want municipal water. I don't
know what municipality you're in, but
it's nasty. You want bottle water,
reverse osmosis water, distilled water.
Uh, you want to be really careful with
water. You're absolutely correct. If you
put municipal city water with your
Beyond Tank Tangerine, the Beyond Tank
Tangerine will actually help clean the
municipal city water, but it's kind of
counterproductive.
>> What do you use for your water?
>> I personally use reverse I use reverse
osmosis water or distilled water.
That's the
>> And a glass jar or bottle.
>> I No, I actually have a plastic bottle,
but that is a good point. Um, you know,
you got to you got to pick your battles
here. You got to do what you can do. So,
but glass would be better. Glass would
definitely be better. You're right.
>> Especially heated plastics can be a
problem. But I do distilled in reverse
osmosis and I suggest everybody does.
And distilled water had there's some
people have misunderstandings about
distilled water. It's clean. That's what
matters. Clean. Clean. Clean.
>> Okay.
>> All right. I do have to
>> Can distilled water leech minerals?
>> I'm sorry. What?
I didn't hear that.
>> Can they Can distilled water leech
minerals from your body? Anybody who
says that should be spanked and kicked
out of your house. That's that's
silliness.
>> All right. Thank you so much, Denise.
And we can get the up on the screen,
>> Denise. And thank you, Becca and AJ and
Coach Rod and Phyllis and Marilyn and
Albert and Tracy and all the Youngevity
distributors. Thank you very much. And
then we're back. If we missed didn't get
you, we'll be back on Monday. Right, AJ?
>> We will be back on Monday. AJ and I'm
gonna go. I'm gonna let you say your
goodbyes. Bye everybody.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you.
>> Thanks Ben.
>> Bye.
>> Folks, if we did not get to your
question, please email them into us
questions at dailywithdoc.com.
On Monday, pharmacist Ben and AJ will be
going through those questions. And next
Friday, we'll be talking about
detoxing from heavy metals. Can you
write that down for me, AJ, please?
Folks, thank you so much for joining
here with us on dailywithdoc.com.
You know, this was a pretty fabulous um
explanation about how the body works,
how we are responsible for it because
nutritionally the doctors don't have the
information that they need in order to
help you nutritionally. They can save
your life all day long with emergency
practices and such, but you are an
empowered individual.
You can't let anybody take that away
from you and it's in your hands to
create a better health journey. Folks,
my name is Becca Dukes. I'm a certified
naturopathic practitioner. I'm also a
certified holistic health coach and the
director of student services for the
Institute of Holistic Health and I am
honored to have the people who are on
the screen with me in addition to being
being able to host this program. Today
we have as our co-host team, we have
Mary who is joining us bringing in
questions. Thank you so much Mary and
learning how to do the system. We also
have Phyllis who is also bringing in
questions and helping to put information
into the chat that is only available if
you're here live with us in the Zoom
which if you'd like to join us live make
sure that you email us
Zoomailywithdoc.com
as we are going to be changing the
process of how you can get in and we
want to make sure those who want to be
here for constructive reasons are still
able to make
Thank you so much, Phyllis. We also have
Marilyn, who is Miss Speedy Fingers,
putting in
um the information in more information
into the chat. So, thank you so much,
Marilyn and Cheryl. You're very welcome.
Thank you so much for being here. I just
saw her comment. Um but thank you,
Marilyn, for all that you do. And Albert
letting people in. Thank you, sir.
joining us from South Africa um in the
middle of his night. Thank you, Albert,
for still being here. And we have Rod
joining us. He's also keeping an eye on
the different platforms to bring
questions in and we did not get to
everybody's question. He was hanging out
with his hand up, waiting patiently. So
again, folks, if you have questions and
we did not get to them or you have
questions that you would like to hear
answered, questions at dailywithdoc.com.
And we have last but not least, AJ, who
is my digital marketing director,
who is the reason why
we posed a question that we knew would
get him all riled up. Because folks,
face it, you put out there what you
really want in the title and you're
going to get blocked.
We don't want that to happen again on
YouTube. But folks, um, just want to do
a shout out to AJ as he's the reason why
we're on multiple different channels so
that if we do get locked out of one,
we're still on at least five others. So,
thank you so much, AJ. And thank you
everybody for investing this hour plus
into your own health and wellness. Get
back with the person that shared this
program with you and tell them thank
you. Ask them how you can get started on
a better health journey. And that Tangy
Tangerine absolutely is probably one of
the best
lifepromoting products that you can give
anybody today, tomorrow, Christmas,
Easter, birthdays. It does not matter.
We need it every single day. Thank you
so much for joining us and we will see
you next time on Daily with Doc and
Becca or Pharmacist Ben Bites and AJ
coming up on Monday. Talk to you later
live at 10 o'clock, 1000 PM Eastern
Monday. Pharmacist Ben Bites. And if
you're watching this and you're not
live, sometimes the time changes. So you
want to make sure that you go to
dailywithdoc.com,
sign up for our email list so that you
can get notifications of the exact times
and who's going to be on the program
each and every time. We are on Monday
through Friday from 12:00 p.m. to 1
Pacific, 1 to 2 mountain, 2 to 3
central, 3 to 4 Eastern, and 9 to 10 in
South Africa at this time of year. Until
next time, bye for now.
[Music]
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
have a founding father of the science of
epigenetics guiding us with the best
options to obtain or maintain optimal
health, Dr. Joel Wall.
[Music]